the campaign against global warming
seems to have gone
bust it started as an effort to protect
the environment it is not that anymore
uc berkeley visiting scholar stephen
hayward just wrote a piece in the wall
street journal detailing how the
movement has been hijacked
by obsessions with race and gender
worries about carbon and rising sea
levels have turned into speeches about
fighting misogyny
and so-called climate justice whatever
that is
stephen hayward joins us tonight to
explain professor thanks for coming on
oh wow thank you tucker isn't it amazing
how everything seems to get reduced to
race and justice these days well yeah
but it's especially amazing when topics
that have
no conceivable connection to race and
gender get pulled in how did that happen
well i mean the whole point of the
article was fairly simple uh most issues
go through these long wave cycles
there's lots of early interest the press
gets onto it
flurry of political activity some
policies are made then we start having
consideration of trade-offs and that's
been going on with global warming for
several years now
it's really expensive to do what a lot
of the climatistas as i call them want
us to do
and so now you're seeing more and more
expressions including in the paris
climate accord that we need to consider
gender equality and climate justice
that's a sign that the issue has as the
cliche goes jump the shark
and why it's kind of at the end of its
string and public opinion surveys here
and in europe show declining public
interest in the whole darn thing well
it's a boutique issue for rich people
obviously but it's also a little
confusing i mean
even if you think that climate justice
is real or even if you can explain what
it is i've never met anyone who can or
if you think that gender equality is
an important part of this what does that
have to do with science it's that's not
science is it
no not at all i mean and that was one of
the things i said in the article is look
i'm not
questioning any of what is called the
consensus about climate science i'm just
saying as a political and policy matter
this has run its course and my goodness
you ought to see my twitter feed blow up
yesterday and today
apparently it's not enough to call
someone a climate denier anymore when
you dissent from climate orthodoxy
i'm getting called a white male
supremacist which is a really a good
sign that you've run out of arguments
about the issue itself
yeah i mean that that doesn't even
approach being an argument
it's it's a primal scream you're at
berkeley how are you allowed to say this
at berkeley what are you doing there
and good for you for being there by the
way well
yeah i i'm like that civil war era
general who said i'd like to foun uh
fights surrounded i think that might
have been general custer though i'm not
sure
look two things two things that you and
your audience should know and maybe be
encouraged by a little bit
one is is that we ought to make a
distinction in all our universities
these days
between old-fashioned liberals who've
dominated universities for decades
that's not a new story
right but increasingly the universities
are being dominated by a much more
radical progressive
left that as we know often turn to
violence to get their way
and a lot of the old-fashioned liberals
understand that this is a crisis for the
universities and a lot of them are
starting to say and this
here i think you want to give props to
the administration and many academics at
berkeley who said
we have a problem and we need to have
some
more conservative voices on our faculty
and on our campus and so
they reached out to me a couple years
ago and invited me to come and i'm glad
to be there i'm having a great time
and i get along with most of the
liberals on the campus just fine
and the radicals won't engage me at all
well i think that's important to make
the distinction i mean if liberalism is
a concern for civil liberties a
commitment to free speech
a belief in actual diversity that i'm a
liberal and proud to be one but
there aren't many left i'm glad you
found you found some brooklyn that's
really heartening professor thank you
there's a great piece well thank you
tucker